[Music]
monica we are so excited for this
do you have a cheer ready for the first
dance no but i think i should probably
get one that's a good thought
oh my gosh what a time it's been for you
the show was so explosive now you're on
dancing with the stars
how does this feel and how have
rehearsals been going well i'm still
pinching myself every day that i'm even
here rehearsals have been going
good you know i'm learning a lot of new
things so
i'm really trying to reteach my body to
use different muscles than what i'm used
to doing
in cheerleading but i've been working
really hard my body's really sore
but i've definitely been putting in the
work both inside the you know dance
studio and back at the apartment
doing everything that i can there to
prepare now you are usually the one
getting your team in their makeup and
their rhinestones and their costumes
what's it going to feel like for the
tables to be turned are you ready to get
a spray tan
no but i'm going to get ready will we
see some cheer moves in the dances
though i mean
we know you as the ultimate cheer coach
that would be fun to do
definitely not uh for the premiere that
we're doing
you know i'm learning everything new
this is something that i'm not used to
doing but
it could definitely be a great creative
uh thing to do to add a little cheer
i would love that because then i would
be definitely in my comfort zone
yeah you're the one who's gonna get
lifted for a change yeah i haven't done
that in a long
time so we'll see how that goes
and how excited was your team for the
news will we see them cheering you on
and watching every week
definitely i'm sure they're going to
have watch parties together to watch
and they are so excited for me i've been
a fan of the show since the very first
season
and my team from years back will tell
you
i talk about the show all the time we
even had a pyramid one year that we
called the dancing with the stars
pyramid because i had
seen this really cool move that someone
did and we incorporated it into our
pyramid so i love the shop in a fan
forever
oh that's awesome so how long have you
known you were going to be on did you
get to personally prepare
not long at all just a few i mean i i
had about a week
before i actually came out here to tie
up loose ends
get get everything ready for me to be
gone for an extended period of time
so i was working really hard at work
trying to get things ready i didn't
really have a lot of time physically
here so we'll see how it goes well we
know you are competitive
so how much do you want to win and how
are you going to win
i definitely my goal is to go out there
and put out the best performance that i
personally
am capable of so i'm really pushing
myself to
to learn the technique and do it
correctly and
improve each practice so um
that's my number one goal to go out
there and do the very best that i can do
and i'm hoping that that with my work
ethic will take me very far
to the end and since i know nothing
about dance that's going to be my
strategy right now
how i prepare mentally and physically
and the time that i'm willing to commit
to put into this
uh competition you're so logical about
everything this is the monica we know
and love
what what's harder to win your cheer
competitions or dancing with the stars
oh my goodness i don't i don't know i
haven't even done week one yet so get
back with me in a few weeks and i'll let
you know
here's the question is jerry gonna give
you
a pep talk every week is he gonna zoom
with you and give you that matte
talk of confidence that you need i'm
definitely gonna make sure that happens
i'm gonna
get a facetime him or something and just
see his face and hear his voice because
it definitely brings
joy to me every single time now another
show was huge uh this year tiger king
carol baskin is on what was your
reaction to carol baskin being
your competition on the show i think
it's great i mean
you know i'm ready to go and uh i think
she's definitely um
you know a big part of 2020 as let's
cheer
so it'll be great to see the two
together who do you think your biggest
competition is
probably johnny ware i would say i mean
i think you're
incredible so what can you tell us about
that first dance
it is definitely something i've never
done before
and the technique and the muscles that i
have to use
are completely different than what i do
in
cheerleading so it has taken me a lot of
work to try to train my
body to stay in a certain position and
i'm still not quite 100
on it yet but my my consistency rate's
getting better